the amount of swear words that negan has
said in the course of the first I think
we're on Episode seven now I have said
everyone as many times as that can be
said now what we do with medium is we
have to film a TV version and I still am
allowed a couple swear words I can drop
them in there and here and there and
then we do what we call it a game and
say at the f take where I just let loose
and I let loose a lot when i am off
camera like if i'm working with other
actors for their coverage when the
cameras on them i will let words fly in
some are scripted and some are just in
character there are rules you earn you
take you should know
this is the only way
things have changed whatever you had
going for you that's over a is I am
everywhere we've been looking for you I
am King Ezekiel welcome to the kingdom
the one back home needs to know about
this any other
I can't let you die out there
hey youtubers is charlie so all the
negan f bombs dropping in about four
weeks let's break it down so Jeffrey
Dean Morgan just so charismatic and
that's part of the charm of negan he
could just talk you in circles just
completely [ __ ] you out of whatever
it is he wants to talk you out of or
into but yeah this is still TV I mean
AMC Walking Dead pretty hardcore
compared to a lot of other cable shows
Network shows for sure but there's just
certain things that they can't do
certain lines they can't cross so what
happens is is when he's talking about
doing the TV version that's what you end
up seeing each week when you watch a new
episode but if you buy the dvds they put
the f-bomb virgin like the F take
version on those so if you want the full
Lucille treatment you have to get the
DVD which I actually think is a really
smart way to do things like if the DVD
is the exact same version of the show
like the exact same type of bonus
features and things that you would see
by watching it on netflix then there's
no reason to buy the DVD so of course
you want to juice it up by making it
much more comic book accurate doing all
the things you'd never be able to do on
TV all the f-bombs and that's just the
beginning nicon is way worse than that I
think you know most of the stuff that he
does they can do in roundabout ways like
bashing someone's skull in in the season
opener so the rumor is is that two
people are actually gonna die which
would be a twist because in the comics
it's really only one person but a lot of
people especially comic book readers are
wondering are they gonna do it and make
it look exactly like the comic book or
will the camera cut away like how
graphic is it going to get I think it'll
probably be hardcore enough that you
reflexively turn your head away even if
the camera doesn't linger on bashed in
said skull I think AMC does have a few
internal rule like they would probably
give notes on something like that like
how many seconds exactly the camera
would be allowed to linger on a
bashed-in skull of a really big main
character that you've been loving for
the last couple of seasons so no worries
maximum trauma will be inflicted if you
have friends that have not been watching
the show episode one of season seven
like the negan bashing would be a really
awesome way to troll them you can just
tell them hey I
this really awesome show it's it's not
that hardcore but it's pretty cool
they're gonna do something really
interesting quote unquote interesting in
the season opener you should check it
out and then just sit back and see if
they spit their drink out when we get to
the nican killing so it's gonna be a lot
of fun I feel like negan coming on the
show was a smart move for them in this
season you know not putting it off any
longer than they had to because in the
comics he was kind of this device to
show people hey Walking Dead is still a
really cool comic they had hit issue 100
sales had gone down quite a bit so
Robert Kirkman wanted to re-energize the
comic and show people hey there's still
so much interesting stuff that has
happened yet so enter negan and even
people at AMC are saying that the
walking dead could go on for forever and
while I don't believe that like that's
kind of overselling it just a little bit
there's still so many big comic book
things like the whispers that they
haven't done yet there are a couple big
conflicts like all-out war that they
haven't got to yet so there's still at
least a couple really big seasons left
in this it's just a question of keeping
the budget under control the main cost
in the later seasons is when actor
salaries get out of control so the best
way to take care of that is just kill
the highest paid actors off the show if
you can but the other big thing in these
trailer like the actual trailers here is
the kingdom and negan in the Savior's so
we're gonna learn all about the Savior's
we're gonna go see where they live their
facilities and we'll see the kingdom
Ezekiel Shiva and everybody's really
excited about Sheba but they definitely
highlight Morgan's character Morgan is
one of those badasses who's kind of been
on the sidelines the last couple of
seasons he had that big go through with
Rick where he's like violence is not the
way so clearly now he's backed off that
a little bit like he built that special
prison at the end of last season so he's
like okay maybe we can do this without
killing people and I should also not
assume that everybody is gonna choose to
do the right thing at least right away
so one of the fun things with this
season I think is that you know
obviously [ __ ] gonna be really
terrible but on the other side of this
equation Ezekiel who seems like he might
be a good person is pretty crazy himself
so it's not like yin and yang it's not
like easy heels gonna be the complete
opposite of negan he has his own issues
and you know without giving away big
spoilers you can read volume 18 what
comes after that's the arc that
introduces him in the comics so if you
want to read along with the comics i
recommend you at least start with volume
18 if you don't want to start before
then because negan debuts like I said an
issue 100 which is the volume 17 like
right before that and then like right
after that volume 18 picks up and you
meet Ezekiel an issue 108 so he was a
couple months after negan but as with
all things the TV show only has about 16
episodes a season so it has to compress
a lot of those comic-book volumes so a
lot of times they'll blend big comic
book arcs but i would expect them to get
close to march to war which is volume 19
but i don't think that they're gonna do
all out where I'd be very surprised if
they did all-out war during this season
so let me know like what are you most
excited for in season 7 I feel like most
people just want to see how crazy it's
gonna get with negan like just show me
how far you're going to go with this so
episode 1 is going to be a good
benchmark in terms of how crazy it's
going to get so like Jeffrey Dean Morgan
says they do the TV pass then they do
the f-bomb pass so there are certain
things that they will change from the
comics but they put it all back in there
for the DVD when you just love to have
an f-bomb version of all the other comic
book TV shows like DC and Marvel stuff
tend to be a little more family-friendly
it'd be so hilarious I would buy DVDs so
quickly if they did f-bomb versions of
episodes but we're about four weeks out
from the premiere as the the trailer set
like they had text over all the trailers
saying October 23rd that's about a week
later that it usually premieres
everything's just like a little bit
later this year so it'll still be Sunday
night's still be a 9pm show so I'm
expecting a little more footage before
it drops so let me know if there's any
Walking Dead bonus videos that you guys
want me to do before the premiere well
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for my Thor funny
moment supercut and you can click here
for all my other Walking Dead Season 7
trailer videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight